hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game a lot of you have
requested that it's from the tapa still
India rapid Edition from round eight to
videot Gujarati versus Wesley so and it
features as you might have seen in the
thumbnail or maybe I'm gonna put it in
the title the greatest opening ever
invented in chess that of course is the
Evans Gambit and uh what happens when
you play it against uh someone like
Wesley so who is a former World official
random Champion so you know that you
know he really does really really well
in the wild and crazy positions and
trying to pull off an Evans Gambit
against someone of Wesley's caliber is
uh well uh just incredible so let's dive
straight into it it's with it with the
white pieces and he opens with Ponte E4
we have E5 Knight to F3 Knights the C6
and the bishop to C4 the Italian game is
on the board with Bishop to C5 The Joker
piano and now the strongest reply to the
Jungle piano B4 of course the Evans
Gambit is on the board and as usual we
challenge the Gambit by accepting it
that is the best way to do it the best
of characters on B4 C3 with Bishop to A5
and now Pawn to D4 I always mention when
there's a uh Evans Gambit game that I
have made a video on the Evans Gambit if
you guys want to check it out it will be
the first link in the description below
if you want to try this as well uh there
we cover all sorts of lines and all of
the Retreats of the bishop like Bishop
act uh A5 to C5 to E7 even to f8 we even
discussed D6 so uh fun stuff so the six
uh even though the E Capture Sun D4 is
still the most popular move here Wesley
goes to pawn to D6 everyone has their
own favorite way of how to deal with the
Evans Gambit Queen to B3 now threatening
Bishop captures and F7 and queen to D7
defending uh we have Castles by uh with
it and now Bishop to B6 this is a move
that you have to remember if you're ever
playing against the Evans Gambit or if
you play the immense gambling because
you will face this move frees up the A5
square and of course this will attack
your queen and the bishop and you will
have part with your light core version
because this is just too strong for
black to allow so here at Knight beat
the D2 We have Knights the A5 attacking
Queen and Bishop the queen back to C2
and not Knight characters on C4 Knight
captures on c for now with tremendous
pressure on that E5 pawn and queen to C6
Wesley knows how to play this uh this is
the absolute best way to challenge this
line and now you're attacking the Knight
and you are forcing white to make some
moves and if if you just try to defend
it to keep the pressure then Bishop G4
and already black is uh black should be
just better the White Queen is stuck now
guarding on F3 and also on C4 so after
Queen to C6 we have Knight captures and
B6 a captures on B6 and now white grabs
back one of the pawns captures captures
and captures on E5 and now Queen to A4
Wesley offers a queen trade with Queen
to D3 and now there is a game where
Knight to F6 was played but here we have
Knights the E7 by Wesley and it is now
as of move 15 mean that we have a
completely new game so let's see how vid
it deals with this he plays Queen to G3
puts pressure on the G7 pawn and also if
the Knight moves the C7 Pawn
uh might be uh in some trouble so uh
Wesley just castles and now Rook the E1
first uh adding a Defender to D for pawn
bishop to E6 and now Pawn to H4 now that
it has a nicely placed Queen and G3 the
bishop can come into the attack the
Knight is a beautifully centralized on
E5 and uh the pawn wants to March all
the way to H6 so hopefully you will also
be able to bring the other Rook into the
game but for the moment it it isn't
really clear how maybe at some point
you're gonna push C for maybe you're
gonna do some Rook lifting uh hard to
say so King the h8 of course Wesley
wants to get uh off of that g file and
pawn to H5 now of course H6 you do not
want to allow white to play Pawn to H6
and the bishop to F4 but it just
continues developing Rook to A5 and now
Rook a D1 will it uh gives up one Pawn
for some uh active play on on the king
side Wesley says all right Queen
captures an A2 and now even Knight to F3
re-maneuvering the Knight offering
another pawn and okay uh since the
village will capture on on C7 and
probably on B6 it's not a problem Rook
captures an A5 Bishop captures and C7 uh
we have Knight to G6 now and Bishop
characters and B6 the bishop will come
to D4 to attack the black king so the
Knight on G6 is uh most excellently
placed so King to H7 and now Bishop to
D4 now this Knight can never move
otherwise Queen to G7 is Checkmate so
Rook the E8 and now Rook the A1
attacking the queen queen to C4 and now
Rook A7 going after the B7 Pawn if virid
grabs this Pawn then the C Pawn becomes
a past pawn and then white has um uh
well just a huge advantage on the queen
side so Queen to C6 defending the B7
pawn and now Rook a back to A1 The Rook
has really no purpose there once the the
B7 Pawn is defended and now Bishop to D7
by Wesley uh remembering the p is maybe
making room for The Rook to enter the
attack also just putting pressure on
that E4 Pawn uh maybe bishop the C8 was
a little bit more precise the also
Defender B7 Pawn while you're at it but
Wesley feels that there is no need for
that so Knight to D2 defending the four
pawn and now Rook to G5 by Wesley now
playing pretty much uh perfect moves
here uh it's very hard for for video to
now get out of this because he has all
this pressure on the black king but with
the Knight on G6 there's just no way to
get rid of it and now Wesley is starting
to get some counter play with an attack
against the white king and already if
you play some weird move lets you play
Queen to D3 uh just Rook G2 and you can
resign because after King captures
Knight F4 check your queen uh will be
lost so uh with it plays the only move
that doesn't lose the game for him Queen
to H2 and now Pawn to F5 by Wesley here
he wants the bus to open the position
Here and Now Rook the A5 the only again
good move for with it now the pawn
cannot move if you advance the pawn or
capture or something just root captures
on G5 the H point is pinned uh so Wesley
just plays Pawn to B5 and this is uh a
moment where vidit has to decide how to
play this it's a very very complicated
position many moves are possible like
you could play C4 you could play F3 here
just try to defend the E4 Pawn which
will weaken your king a little bit but
it might be necessary however with it
played Queen Rook day seven uh he wants
to play Queen to C7 which you will
probably see in the thumbnail uh but uh
it does not work F captures an E4 and
now Queen to C7 and yes it's very nice
Queen and Rook on the seventh rank the
bishop also helping out with the attack
against the G7 Pawn uh there's all
already the thread of Queen characters
and C6 Bishop captures and Rook captures
on G7 so it seems like all is well and
that he's basically just forcing a queen
trade however Wesley has a
such a spectacular win here if he finds
the correct continuation which he did
not in the game but that's where you
guys come in feel free to pause the
video here and win the game for Wesley
uh while I give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this uh
outstanding idea and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
Pawn to E3 and now when you see it of
course you immediately believe it
because uh not only are you attacking
the Knight and not only are you
attacking the edf2 pawn you're also
threatening mate in one with Queen
captures and G2 and the only thing left
for white to try here is the trade
Queens but even that is insufficient
look at this queen captures on C6 now
you don't recapture but rather you play
e captures on D2 now you're threatening
a d captures anyone with uh with
queening and there there's just nothing
you can do yeah if you try to go for
some Checkmate and you allow black to
grab a queen then anything just King H2
and knights the E5 now prevents any
checkmates and now white is getting
checkmated and of course if you capture
the rug then it's just an instant Knight
to F3 check captors Queen G1 check King
H3 and queen cage one Checkmate so that
of course doesn't work so after he
captures on D2 you're gonna have to move
the Rook there's no other way to do it
but now I mean again anything is winning
uh you you are defending the D2 Pawn but
just Rook the E1 with check and again
not a way to do it if you capture we get
a queen into the game if you play King
the H2 uh then Rook captures on D1 and
white is just not in time if white plays
Queen captures on D7 then black has this
beautiful Rook the H1 with check and as
the root covers the G file you are
forced to capture if if you weren't
forced to capture you might be able to
survive because you are threatening
Checkmate but after captors D1 queen or
even better not D1 Queen a rook to H5
check first and now after King to G1 D1
Queen will be Checkmate or if you block
with the queen to try and give back some
material again D1 Queen and after King
H2 just wrote captures on H3 and that's
pretty much it now you're just down too
much material to try and play this so
that's what was possible after Queen to
C7 and that's why this game is is so
spectacular but Wesley missed it this is
a rapid game so of course you're not
gonna see everything Knight to fate was
played Wesley defended the the bishop on
D7 and now with it successfully just
traded down Queen captures Bishop
captures Bishop E3 attacks The Rook Rook
to D5
and Rook the C7 now uh Bishop to D7 the
bishop is here nicely defended by the
rook and Rook to A1 now uh we have
knighted the E6 and now Rook to B7 uh if
it still tries to get some sort of uh
pressure sorry another Rook day seven uh
first Rook the B7 uh as the Knight
attacked the rook and now Rook the D3
uh Rook 887 Bishop to C6 now attacking
the rook and now you have to trade uh
Rook D7 captures captures and now they
just trade down Bishop D5 Knight
captures an E4 King to G6 and now Knight
to D6 going after the B5 Pawn so Rook
captures in C3 Knight captures and B5
and The Rook to B3 attacks the Knight
and here they just trade off everything
Knights the D4 Knight captures Bishop
captures and The Rook to B7 Rook
captures Bishop captures and it was in
this position on move 47 that uh Wesley
and vidis resigned agreed to a draw as
there is nothing more to be done here is
equal material Bishops are of opposite
color so there's nothing more to try
here
so brilliant game by both of them uh
Wesley have it in this moment after
Queen the C7 had he found E3 it would be
a spectacular victory for him but the
game ends in a draw and it is a village
who joins the ranks of great men who
have attempted the diamonds Gambit on
the highest level uh and lived to tell
the story uh so yeah and that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it I would like to
thank the animated chemistry textbook
KGB sellers anti booty consultants
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check to all my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing to check up
on your wonderful suggestions and
everything else that happens in the
Chess World so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day